morning we challenged ourselves to
reinvent the notebook the new MacBook
weighs just 2 pounds this is the
lightest Mac we have ever made
it's a Retina display comes in silver
Space Gray and a stunning gold hashtag
MacBook lust at just $12.99 now I'd like
to turn to the newest addition to the
Apple family now the watch is the most
personal device we have ever created
every Apple watch has many different
faces and many different configurations
you can even check your heart rate and
this is clearly not mine at this point
in time I'd like to invite Kevin Lynch
off Kevin well you can use Apple watch
to actually pay for things while you're
checking out I've got my credit cards
right inside my watch to bring one up
all I have to do is double tap the side
button and it brings up my credit card
recent photos for my friends on
Instagram if I'd like to see a little
bit more I can tap on that glance it
takes me to the Instagram app on my up
the watch and here I can see some photos
here comes the phone call right now I'm
going to answer right on my Apple watch
hi this is Kevin hi and the great thing
is that Apple watch communicates with
your iPhone over Wi-Fi as well as
Bluetooth so when you're home you don't
have to be within Bluetooth range of
your phone and now I can actually
control the garage door remotely with my
watch so open the door it's gonna send
the command to my garage door and it
should open there it goes during a
typical day you can expect 18 hours that
works for most people I think we've
curated Apple watch into three
collections the first collection is the
Apple watch sport
now the Apple watch sport starts at only
$349 for the 38 millimeter model and
only $50 more for the 42 millimeter
model the Apple watch collection also
comes in two sizes the 38 millimeter
starts at only 549 and ranges to 10 49
depending upon your selection of the
watch band Apple watch Edition is
something unbelievably unique and very
special their cases are made from 18
karat solid gold it is priced from
$10,000 and it will be available in
select retail stores we're taking
pre-orders beginning on April the 10th
and it will be available in many
countries throughout the world